in supply in some in some in supply I
love it probably
[Music]
[Music]
first is foremost happy birthday
tomorrow there to be as a birthday must
hope you have the best day ever kept me
see you later today in Philly but the
rip faces off in the City of Brotherly
Love
exhalation
I got a little bit yeah yeah how do you
know if you're being delusional or
patient giving up as hard than sometimes
your attorney
that's a great question the answer is I
can't answer that for you I really can't
that's an incredibly thoughtful question
look 99% of people give up at the proper
time not but 1% of people give up a week
before if they would have made it I
think you look at past results to tell
you future results but other times
things turn you know it's a feeling one
has to know when it's time when it's
time in life in general and I think
something you're good at it I think some
people are bad at it so what I would say
is the most important thing that I think
about is you would never know the
alternative if you if you stopped
because it hasn't been working and
you've been patient for three and a half
years but now you think you've crossed
over into the delusion you'll just never
know and I'm gonna pay with that there's
so many things that I could have done so
many paths that I could have taken some
people are pessimistic look at glass
half-empty and always think back I
should have married that person I should
have took that job I should have
invested in that stock I just don't have
that gear and I would spend much more
time on having the gear of being
optimistic and knowing that you can't
control the past or that you won't know
the alternative of your decisions and
that makes you more optimistic and
positive and happy and go forward and
faster I think it's about the mindset of
knowing that you would have never known
otherwise more so than what's the right
time or not nobody can answer you not
back not me not nobody you just have to
answer for yourself play the hand and
move on period end of story the end no
matter how much content you're producing
for whatever you're trying to achieve
whether that's to raise money for the
PTA or sell sneakers or build your real
estate firm or whatever you do the one
thing for all the people here in front
and all those homies that I love so much
in the back
man it takes a while for noise to get
the [ __ ] up here all the good [ __ ]
that's going on with me I literally
think I mean nothing I mean that's
serious do I think I'm the greatest of
all time with my confidence of bravado
and ego and excitement and the things I
see are happening but I easily know them
when I if I disappeared tomorrow cool
I'd have a good social media day and
then everybody would I'm telling you
when prints of David Bowie died in that
little window and I watched those icons
of culture get about 24 hours of love
and then everybody forgot I was like
[ __ ] right I mean it I mean it and so
what's really empowering and what's
holding so many people back here is
entitlement you feel like somebody owes
you something because something went
wrong somewhere along the way I don't
I actually think whatever went wrong for
you is the best [ __ ] that ever happened
to you because adversity is absolutely
the foundation of success
the other thing I know is I have bad
news
nobody gives a [ __ ] about your problems
and this is super important to
understand the second you actually
understand that nobody actually gives a
[ __ ] the only people that listen to you
complaining are your loser [ __ ]
friends if you like complaining like
just take a step back look around the
next time you're complaining about the
government or or you know racial or
feminine or yeah I had a guys in front
of me the other day crying that his life
was bad because he was a white male rich
white male I was like all this [ __ ]
we've got everywhere that
you're either on the offense or defense
I just want you to know something one of
the things that's been really on my mind
is I think a lot of people think they're
in the middle they're like in a transit
you're only on the offense or the
defense and I realized that I've been on
the offense my whole life because I
never felt entitled to anything an
incredible thing happens when you're
born with very little you know is born
in the Soviet Union we come to America I
live in a studio apartment in Queens you
know my parents brought me six toys in
my entire life kind of thing we took one
one family vacation in my entire life
right when I want a Nintendo my mom
looked me dead in the face and said good
go buy it and that was huge on the flip
side what she also did was she instilled
she let me rephrase she reinforced
things that came natural to me and made
them the most important things while I
was getting D's and F's and every other
immigrant parent was making their kids
get A's and B's because they thought
that's what mattered my mom was
accelerating and going out of her mind
anytime that I showed compassion anytime
that I showed empathy anytime that I
showed gratitude and honestly for all of
you that watched me it's what I'm doing
for my community with my content we my
friends more than ever now we need to
focus on the truth here's the tree
this second that we're sitting here is
the greatest second in the history of
mankind
for human beings I love this woman so
much so [ __ ] much
and so what guys are still
post-production it wow we're tweaking it
or like what what's holding you back got
it then give it the most noise possible
guys it's telling you it's Instagram
accounts whether it's worldstar whether
it's Gary Vee whether its yadi whether
it's you know it's just it's Instagram I
kept like just go in a cocoon and get
like 50 people that have love for you
and be like yeah we will put out the
first one or the third one or these ten
people are doing the first one these
ones that I remember you're doing in
that kind of way like if that's what it
is there's like ten people on Instagram
could do more for you than [ __ ] it like
it's a different game it's Lauren's the
[ __ ] talk I just gave
like you get ninja to [ __ ] like
Wally's playing for night be like oh
this is phat from here that's all you
need
I'm comfortable in both you just like if
you had 14 million followers on
Instagram you wouldn't be thinking about
those you just put on your own [ __ ]
right you guys have so many people that
like me that know what you're about to
be it's good for them they either like
you or they know that you're gonna be
huge I'm both
so I'm easy but they're either one or
the other and that's selfish for them
you got to sit down and go in a bunker
and start asking if any time you can't
wait man what's your name
that's right thank you thank you man
listen if you're right people people
love to play the part right people love
to play the part like it's the same way
about keyboard warriors let's go then I
told you about which is like people
pleasure got you think so yo you just
rolled up like [ __ ] crazy up in here
bring so here's my thing and for again
for you to be at this conference people
some of you that follow me heavy you
guys know this I love when people email
me and say they're not watching me
anymore
I'm done with you Gary Vee I'm thrilled
I'm not in here to monetize my audience
I get sad when they're like okay cuz I
say it a lot like stop watching me and
go do you like how many more
motivational books do you need how many
more videos do you have to watch like
what you're doing is you're getting a
short second euphoria kind of feeling
because you feel like you're on the
verge of doing something but it's only
about the doing something and
unfortunately there's a lot of people
making a lot of money making you feel
good for a few seconds I literally think
about motivation and things that the way
I think about the drug industry in
America we're not fixing [ __ ] we're just
making money I'm pausing [ __ ] or
stretching [ __ ] out I would be thrilled
if you never bought a book never watched
a video my concern is a lot of times
people say that to me and then I watch
because I'm always curious I said it
earlier I don't want you anymore Gary B
I got it but then they're watching
somebody else that's a dull a diluted
version of it they just wanted to say to
me they don't watch anymore you know
it's doing you can't read about doing
push-ups you got to do them and then you
get the results
attendees so basically I'm the girl who
goes there mix for the waterfront place
and I actually teach people how to do
their do this effectively in supply in
song and some can supply like I love it
probably
put it put it all on there put it all
out there like don't people are
overthinking it dumb people are telling
you things like start three accounts
this that the other thing they put it
all out there you are you you are you I
post [ __ ] about wine on my account not
everybody's like 98 percent of my
audience on incident doesn't want to see
me talking about a wine they're there to
get motivated or a trick or a business
thing I don't give a [ __ ] I want to talk
about wine and guess what some of them
want to buy wine too they're tired of
buying dumb [ __ ] from especially when
you live in a [ __ ] state like
Pennsylvania liquor control [ __ ]
anyway so you know how all your truths I
don't know what my big thing is this
always look at the person giving the
advice that's my advice show me who's
giving you the other advice I'm very
fascinated by this people are always
like Gary but this person told me to do
this and I'm like what the [ __ ] is that
person doing and first of all [ __ ] my
advice do you forget about Gary Vee or
Sally [ __ ] Thompson do you you want
to talk about [ __ ] supply chain from
China today post you want to [ __ ]
write of LinkedIn article today about
real safe post you want to [ __ ] film
you on Beijing air [ __ ] landing post
my dear everybody here is overthinking
at the cost of doing everybody here is
either overthinking and using
perfectionism as an excuse to not do the
doing it's only the doing got it I gotta
go see you I'm sorry thank you so much
crazy how much I like people interaction
I know yeah it was just like thinking
I'm like it's so interesting how much
that is my currency you know I just
feels nice I think it's a nice thing to
do to like acknowledge some of the
awesome stuff you know so it's like that
like even if you see how he reacted just
like nothing crazy but just like not
like so unexpected a nice
regional
being here for an hour every year that's
cool that's cool
coming to that
I would do that it's a good idea I was
way better an idea than I thought was
gonna come out of your mouth no I mean
it was a really good idea [ __ ] [ __ ]
my pants how are you thank you oh my God
my so jealous nice meeting you take care
you're welcome yeah I did I did send a
picture to imagine
sure
thanks men you guys yeah real pleasure
to have this perfect yet to care
such a good piece of content
we never do that but the other we never
do anything like funny per se like
nothing like like like bro banter you
know so funny
and we just I made a good base I use my
comedic capabilities
well is that like is that a challenge
[Music]
take your shirt off looking at you
[Music]
this is what the blog should be the
constant rising
[Music]
Hey
trying to catch up with you in your own
hand here
the media right now under guard
people's help at night that's it in that
area like getting Justin and Sophie like
you need to figure out the [ __ ] out
route straight up see a good trip
see the wine project meeting
accomplished the keynote funny funny
moment happy birthday mama
[Music]
Oh
[Music]